airman marquez for the rockies better in
his start at st louis on sunday when he
went six innings gave up two runs one
earned winker playing in
right field tonight rocky's shift on the
infield they leave story as the only man
on the left side fuentes moves over to
the right oh two pitch swang and a miss
might have been foul tipped but held on
to by elias diaz
airmon gets his first punch-out wade
miley of the reds a really really good
outing his last timeout on friday a
no-hitter against the indians garrett
hampson is going to lead it off in
center field
hit home run number four last night in
the eighth inning to help the rockies to
the win and he'll start this off with a
ball hit to the gap it's going to roll
all the way to the wall in deep left
center hampson with his speed cruises
into third base with a stand-up triple
his second of the year
here's trevor's story trevor
sat out last night he's been in a little
bit of a down turn
and a throw to first and the ball gets
away
from mustaches at first and hampson
comes home
[Applause]
boy you can really tell story taking a
lot of time going out of the box
stepping back in trying to disrupt the
rhythm of miley the 3-2 swinging a miss
struck him out and it was a cutter down
and out of the zone story chased it
and that is out number one
jana vandaza looking for a two out hit
to add to the rockies advantage
here's the 3-2
and strike three caught right at the
knees change up from miley locked up
dazza a beautiful pitch right at the
bottom of the zone daws and dreckman
talk it over the inning is over the
rockies do get one
and here's kyle farmer
farmer getting the chance to play a
short
pitch
line to left and dazza reaches up and
somehow
caught a ball he had no business
catching
he misjudged that liner
realized at the end it was going to go
over his head
and somehow skied to grab it two on for
connor joe
strike three friends have the tiger to
third and the go ahead run it second
and it'll be jesse winker
on a little shot back up the middle off
the leg of marquez he'll make the play
to first base
and wade miley will come around to score
and naquin goes to third so a little
comebacker right there winker get picks
up an rbi on the put out all right now
mike moustakas
mustachis has reached safely coming into
this ball game in eight of his last 16
played appearances
over one tonight swung on off the end of
the bad down the third baseline gonna be
a tough play the first base
overthrow at first base the ball goes
wild naquin comes around to score
mustaches rolls into second base
and the reds have taken the lead
so suarez now with mustaches down at
second base
marcus ready and the pitch swing and a
miss
who got suarez on a breaking ball and
that'll do it for the reds in the third
they get two
first and third for fuentes
make sure you put it in play 2-1 pitch
he does put it in play but it's in the
air popped into short right field going
out india coming in winker neither will
get it bounces fair coming in to score
trevor story
rbi single for fuentes and the game is
tied at two
dozen struck out looking his first time
up after being ahead in the count 3-0
mustac
was playing up and now he backs up
behind the runner dazza swings and
dribbles it up the middle for a base hit
blackman around third he's going to come
to the plate
over to third base goes fuentes and it's
an rbi hit for daza and the rockies jump
back up 3-2
and now we'll see if diaz can
come up with a base hit how much would
he like that
3-2 rocky's lead still nobody out
runners at the corners and again the
reds infielders up the middle
playing for two and diaz rips it into
left field that'll score fuentes around
a third goes dazza and elias diaz
delivers the rbi knock 4-2 rockies
here's the pitcher airman marquez the
pitch marquez bunts it right side hugs
the line miley can't field the ball
everybody's safe daz scores to make it
5-2
ground ball at somebody gets you out of
the inning connor joe the hitter
1-1 swung on a ground ball but suarez
the second base over to first in time
double play
around the corner five four three ends
the rockies third but in the inning they
score four so here's jonathan india now
with a runner in scoring position in the
rockies up five to two
mark is ready check second the o2 pitch
swing and a miss got him on a breaking
ball and the reds are denied in the
fourth
fuentes is one for two with an rbi
pitch to fuentes and make it ten hits as
he drives the ball down the left field
line story will trot home blackman over
to third double and an rbi for josh
fuentes and the rockies add on they lead
it six to two and here's jonathan dazza
charlie blackmon has come out of the
ball game
pinch runner at third
holds that glove up by his shoulders
kicks and fires in that's a line drive
base hit into left center field one run
is in around third is blackman he will
score sliding into second base safe with
a two-run double
is iana than daza and the rockies extend
the lead again it's eight to two marquez
sacrificed bunt
but reached on an error
last inning he doubled his first time up
the pitch strike three called right on
the outside corner marquez down on
strikes the inning is over here's elias
diaz
there's a ground ball headed for second
india flips to farmer at the bag one
around to first that's a double play
four six three to close out the rocky
six this game rolls to seven and now
jonathan india
akiyama
average lead at first here comes the
pitch by marquez swung on a high fly
ball deep center field there goes the
center fielder back and
bye bye baseball
home run jonathan india his second in as
many nights this one out of the big
man's part of the ballpark
and garrett hampson to take his turn
been a good night for
a lot of guys in the upper and middle
part of the order 14 hits for the
rockies garrett with a couple of them
pitch to hanson is swung on and hit well
to left field back it goes over and out
of here
garrett hampson with number five and his
second home run in as many nights
and the rockies get a run back they lead
nine to four
suarez over three now suarez hammers one
deep left way back and gone
hey eugenio suarez a two-run shot
don't go anywhere it's 9-6 rockies
suarez with his seventh home run of the
year rockies have two on with two out
and here is elias diaz
warren to the plate to diaz breaking
ball hit in the air right field right at
jesse winker he makes the catch doesn't
even have to move side retired two outs
in the ninth nine six rockies
[Applause]
jesse winker is single in four tries and
a run batted in
2-2 pitch
bouncing ball to first grabbed by
fuentes gets to the bag balking